so chip four sides is the founder of
rebel coast winery which is actually the
world's first winery to ever go through
a tech incubator and the reason why I
wanted him to come because he is the
most unorthodox startup founder I've
ever met he's pretty wacky dude but he's
been able to successfully have his
personality bleed into his brand and
that's what he's gonna be talking about
so please welcome chip Forsythe so my
brother and i started making wine in
college originally to meet girls and
that did not work out at all so we ended
up having a ton of wine to sell so we
ended up selling it to all the kids in
the dorms for the next three years we
would steal grapes from people's
vineyards bootleg it under a bridge and
and then just sell it to anybody that
had you know five ten bucks for a bottle
of wine when I was had to graduate the
idea to actually build of legit winery
came around we raised a seed round
started building this company I brought
on two of my friends to help me do this
and it turned out to be one of the most
painful lessons I ever learned because a
year and a half later we're growing
really rapidly and so a year to have
later were growing really rapidly and
we're no longer friends we had what i
like to call the great divorce i don't
know if you guys have started or started
a company it's tough tough times and i
ended up selling the winery so then took
some time off goofed around and decided
to make another winery to get back into
the business so I raised this another
seed round and started building a
products that I did not love or care
about it all and I was faking this
product I was trying to do what everyone
else in the space was doing about that
time I got into Adam Draper's incubator
and he took me aside and he was like hey
man what's going on like you're
struggling this is tough you're not
building anything that you can actually
get behind like build something you can
live build something you can love so we
ended up scrapping everything that we
were doing because I was faking it I was
building a product that I was faking it
everyone could see it it was so obvious
and so we scrapped what we were doing
and started over and it ended up costing
around thirty thousand dollars to get
rid of this product that we had already
started making and put out on the market
and that's when rebel coast my new
winery was born and it we decided to
build something that we could be really
passionate about and build a brand that
was really really enjoyable so that was
me up there and we ended have only
making one wine and putting everything
of our every part of our personality
into it and the goal was to make
something that would tell our story even
if we weren't there and we absolutely
loved what we were doing and the good
thing about when you love what you do
you're more you've got more leeway and
everything so as a prank i put my other
two co-founders cell phone numbers on
about 10,000 corks each I didn't tell
him about it and we bottled this wine
and it worked out really well in our
favor and it was something really fun we
did the good thing is we were in a
really antiquated archaic industry so if
you go against the grain in any way you
get a lot of attention and we ended up
building a cult following effortlessly
overnight and its really helped drive
everything that we're doing and the good
thing about that is in any industry that
anybody's in attention is huge and it
didn't cost us a dollar to get this huge
amount of attention that we got and it
wasn't just for the wine we were making
like that was a secondary thing
everybody was excited about why why we
were doing this to this day we still get
unsolicited a couple hundred resumes a
month and it's from people who have
never heard about or never even tasted
or why in the majority of their like hey
what you're doing looks really fun how
do we get into it and if you're building
a company getting people that are
interested in working with you and
helping build is awesome and this is a
traditional sales team on how people in
our industry normally sell wine and it
is we learned very fast this was not us
and that nobody could sell wine better
than us so we cloned ourselves and built
a sales team this is half of our team
you know this couple of six months ago
but we just in not a single one of these
people is in this for the Paycheck that
they get there any because they love
what they're doing they love being
around us because we're passionate about
everything the good news is is if you're
passionate about something not only do
other people see it but potential
investors see it and it makes it a lot
easier to bridge that gap between hey I
need money and hey do you want to be
part of this so we've been able to great
together a great group of investors to
help us get started and that's very true
with even like Kickstarter campaigns the
most successful ones are because people
are funding why someone's doing
something not the actual end product so
if you can incorporate that into your
actual business it makes life a lot
easier cuz we have easy I know
everybody's you know either started a
company or fundraisers are trying to
fundraise it's very very difficult don't
let anyone ever tell you otherwise and
if you can have just a little bit more
passion in what you're doing then it's
going to make life a lot easier that's
pretty much it for my speech I tricked
my co-founder to taking this picture so
I wanted to work it in here yeah but
yeah if you could be passionate about
what you're doing then life's going to
be a lot easier and everyone's going to
see it and people are going to want to
be around you and help you out along the
way